I can't make jokes about the
Holocaust, even though I've noticed that my generation has gotten really good at that
because we have all this distance and supposedly it's our way of neutralizing it. But it's really
close to home for me because I was raised by a Holocaust
survivor. My grandmother, who lost every living relative in the
war and was liberated from Bergen Belsen in 1945.
Three years later she came to United States and joined the Satmar Hasidic
Sect. The Satmar Hacidic Sect believed that the Holocaust had happened
as a punishment for assimilation and for
Zionism and that the only way to prevent another one from happening again
was for Jewish people to lead a very austere life of deprivation with fanatical
adherence to ritual and
tradition.  That worked for a lot of Holocaust survivors who felt guilty but
strangely enough it didn't work for my grandmother. She raised me because my parents arranged marriage
had fallen apart when I was very young and my mother had left the community.
Divorce was a tremendous scandal in the Satmar World.  It didn't happen.
And it affected the reputation of our family deeply and because I was
a reminder of my parents' divorce I was seen as a stain on my family.
And I was considered an outcast by my peers.
I spent my childhood feeling...resented as
if no one wanted me around
except my grandmother never made me feel that way. She made
me feel loved.
She made me feel seen. And she made me feel
safe. And I clung to her, I spent time with her in her kitchen and I watched as she cooked
and baked very complicated foods. And I listen to her as she's sang
Chopin and
Liszt. And I went down with her to the little garden that she kept in the backyard of our Brooklyn
brownstone where she grew beautiful pink climbing roses. And she was the source of
everything that was beautiful and joyful in my life. And she's the
reason that I am a redeemable human being.  When I was ten
years
old I went through her lingerie drawer
because I wanted to find out if she was hiding anything because we never talked and I was so curious about
her.  And between her old fashioned silk slips I
found a spy novel
In English.  In the Satmar community English books are forbidden,
As is movies, and
music, and radio, and newspapers. And I thought,"Wow
my grandmother read books." This was huge because at that point.
I had started sneaking out of the community to the Brooklyn public
library where I too was reading forbidden secular books. And the moment when I saw that
spy novel I realized that even though my grandmother and I could never talk about our shared secret
it was somehow OK. There wasn't
anything wrong with me for reading.
One day I went to the library. And the librarian who knew me at this point, and who knew that
I shouldn't have been there, came over to me, and she didn't say anything because she knew I would have been scared but she gave
me a book, and the book was 'The Diary of Anne
Frank'. I had never heard of Anne Frank.
I thought it was a novel.
I started to read
it and I fell in love with Anne.  Because who wouldn't fall in love with Anne? She's wonderful.
Her voice was so full of hope and purity. And she commented
on the injustice in the world around her and her hopes and dreams for her future,
much in the same way I did in my little journals that I kept secret.
And I became very invested in her future. Because it felt like being invested in my own
future.  And then Anne went to Bergen
Belsen. And I stopped. And I realized this was real.
I knew about Bergen Belsen. I didn't know what had happened there but I knew the name. And I
kept reading and Anne witnessed the most tremendous
in humanity and suffering and suddenly I
realized that that was what my grandmother had endured and witnessed.
And then Anne dies,
and it was like a part of my grandmother had died and I started to cry. And I cried all the way
home. And it wasn't regular crying. It was the kind of crying that I can
only describe as the crying a child will exhibit when
they are dealing with the trauma that they are not equipped to
process. Because you can't calm down.  You can't
stop and so by the time I open the door to our house and I walked in, and I had to go past
my grandmother, who is in the kitchen, to my room. I was bawling. And I couldn't breathe.
And of course my grandmother noticed. And she followed me to my room. And she wouldn't let me close the door and she
says, '??Mamalo!?? What's wrong? What happened? Why are you crying so
hard? And I didn't know what to tell her because I couldn't tell her because I couln't tell her the truth. I couldn't tell her I'd been
going to the library because everyone would find out and I would be in trouble.
But I didn't know what excuse to give her because what would be plausible for this reaction. So I lied.
I said I had been on
the bus and somebody had left a copy of this book, and I picked it up, and it was the Diary of Anne Frank
and I said '??Bubby?? Now I know what you went through. I know and I don't understand how to make
it OK. I don't unders--I don't know how to stop crying. I don't know how to keep living please tell
me something that will make it
OK. Because I don't,
I don't know how to
live with this knowledge that this is what you went through.
And she turned white, and she shut the door,
and she didn't answer me.
And we never talked about it again.
When I was 22 years old I left the Satmar Hacidic Sect because it was a place
where I felt confined and I couldn't be
myself. I had to cut ties with everyone I ever knew
including my grandmother who is the most precious thing that I have
lost. But that question I asked her so many years
ago that was never answered stuck with me. And it became much more urgent all
of a sudden as I had started over from scratch
not knowing where my new home would be, or what kind of person I would be in the future, I needed to
understand how she had been through something like this on a much grander scale and how she
had endured. So I embarked on the trip.
I was going to go to Europe. And I was going to retrace her entire journey from the place where she
was born until the port that she sailed to America from. And I
did that. And I started in Hungary. And I worked my way along the concentration camp
trail.  And on the way I met a lot of Germans.
And I remembered that the one belief about the Satmar Community that my grandmother had ascribed to
was that all Germans were
evil. And that secretly, even if they pretended to be nice to you, they wanted
to kill me because I was Jewish.
So I decided to test that theory.
I would walk up to German people and in a very hostile aggressive way I would ask
them these probing questions about their ancestry. "What did your grandparents do during the war?"
"Are you an
anti-Semite?" Invariably all of
their grandparents were in the resistance. None of them knew any
anti-Semite. 'This is fishy,' I thought.
Then I met Marcus, in a bar in Munich and I asked him what did
your grandparents do during the war, were they in the resistance
too? Actually he said, 'My grandfather was in the
SS. I remember my grandmother used to brag about kissing Hitler's
hand.' And I was not prepared for someone to say
'Yes'. And we talked. And suddenly I realized that he was very handsome.
In a typical Arian
way. And he was smart and his German accent--
it sounds so awful to say this--but it was really sexy.
And he looked at me and he said,
'I didn't know people like you were real! I thought you were just in Woody Allen
movies.' And this was before the Woody Allen scandal so I was only a little
bit
insulted. But anyway. An
hour later we fell into bed. And we stayed there for six hours. And
then he traveled with me to the concentration
camps. I went to Bergen
Belsen.  At Bergen Belsen I saw a photograph. It
was
a photograph that the B.B.C. had taken upon liberation and there were
piles of corpses in the
photograph and women sitting up amongst the corpses,
these indescribable expression on their faces. And I looked at
the photo when it was blown up in front of me and I realized, 'my grandmother was
there. She saw that!' And I became
filled with a tremendous, explosive rage.
I was so angry. I wanted to murder somebody.
And of course the best person to take all my anger out on was: Marcus.
Marcus
he, he took it though, he wouldn't abandon me.
And we went on with our trip from Holocaust site to holocaust site.
And somehow we just couldn't separate and then at the end of our itineray he said to
me  "Do you want to meet my mother?"
And I thought. The man I'm dating wants me to meet his mother?
And then I thought. The man I'm dating wanted me to meet his mother who was raised by Nazi's.
And I said yes and we went to
Frankfurt. And I was very nervous and I practice my greeting in German which is really complicated because
they don't just say. Nice to meet you. They have a long series of verbs one after the other that
basically translates to it's nice to get to learn to know you. And I practice and practice which
verb came first and of course I knock on the door and she opened and I said it all backwards.
But it's fine. She was nervous too. And I got into her apartment. And it was
beautiful and immaculate. And it was, there were knick knacks everywhere. My grandmother would have
called them tchotchke's. And she took me out to her garden.
And in her garden. There were beautiful pink climbing roses. Just like
the ones my grandmother had
grown. And I looked around at her place and I looked at her and I looked at her garden I
thought. I think they would have liked each other. My grandmother and this woman.
Except for the German thing. And then we sat down on her terrace
and we talked. And I asked her about it.
I said "How are you different?
How is it that you were raised by these people, and you're not this way." And she
said "It's a good question. My parents were racist until their dying
day. But you have to understand I was part of a generation that wanted nothing to do with
that. Everyone around me was rebelling. And I'm not special. It was just something that we didn't want to be
a part of." And she looked very sad and I and I asked her "what's wrong? Why why
are you so sad?" and she said "You're the first Jew I've ever met.
I've never had to really think about what my parents had done or what kind
of impact
their actions had had in the lives of others. But now that you're here I have to think
about that."
And I said "no, that's not why I'm here, that's not what I want. I want to let go of all that. I don't want this,
this hate and this, and this trauma to last forever. I'm here to let go
of that. I want to escape that. And it, it's okay, I just want my life to be filled with love and
forgiveness." and she looked at me and she said
"It's easy for the victims to say they forgive.
The guilty cannot forgive themselves."
And I didn't know if I believed myself.
And I didn't know if I believed her either
when we talked about
that. But we wrapped up the trip. And I went home. And
I stopped thinking about the Holocaust twenty four seven. Marcus came to visit me
in the States. And we weren't going to concentration camps we were going to farmers markets.
and he was normal. We were just a couple and,
I thought I was in love and that this was going to
work. And then one day, as he was leaving for the airport he asked to borrow
a book for the plane ride home. And I surveyed my bookshelves. And I thought what could
I give him that I really
like. And then I found something and I pulled it from the shelf and it was Nathan Englanders collection of
short stories titled. 'What We Talk About When We Talk About Anne
Frank.' And I gave it to him. And a few days later we Skype and I said What did you think
of the book.
And he said. I'll be frank with you. It's a bit
Jew overload for me. And I said honey.
Nathan Englander is Jew overload for you but you're dating me.
And I thought I had given up so much. In my life. To be free,
to be one hundred percent me.
And I really needed to live a life where I could talk about Anne Frank.
Thank you.